don't wait anymore don't think anymore
don't plan anymore don't contemplate
anymore don't make any more excuses
don't accept the faults don't give
yourself the benefit of the doubt you've
got to be your own harshest critic start
small start with changing tomorrow
morning just tomorrow morning need
motivation what a top ten with a bully
nation what's up believe nation it's
heaven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference in the world
so let's get your motivation to attend
and get you believing in you grab a
snack and chewing today's lessons from a
man who went from being a Navy SEALs
commander and receiving the Silver Star
and Bronze Star for his service to
become an influential podcaster and
author he's jockle willing and here's my
take on his top 10 Rose a success vol 4
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one - my personal favorite step
aggressively towards your fear you've
lived a life dominated by doubt and fear
how do you step into bravery step that's
how you step into bravery step take the
step step aggressively toward your fear
and that that step towards your fear is
the step into bravery because we're per
scared of what we don't know and there's
only one way to learn and to know and
that is to confront that fear you have
to step you have to go and this simple
action this simple attitude it answers
so many questions so many questions how
do you get to the gym every day you step
you go how do you how do you change your
diet you step you go how do you overcome
fear of failure fear of success or fear
of fear itself
you step and how do you face the fear of
the unknown your step don't wait anymore
don't think anymore don't plan anymore
don't contemplate anymore don't make any
more excuses or justifications don't
rationalize anything else no no and no
instead
be aggressive take action now and what
is the first action that you need to
take what's the first step you need to
take the first step you need to take is
just that step rule number two
I'll fight the enemy it is not easy to
identify the enemy in combat in war so
what you have to do is you have to
control what you can control right you
got to be prepared you've got to train
you've got to study
you've got to rehearse you've got to
remain vigilant you've got to maintain
discipline and everything you do so that
when the enemy does reveal itself you
have the ability to think it to out
maneuver to out fight the enemy and it's
actually the same thing in business
right the enemy can be hard to identify
your competitors aren't broadcasting
their next move you don't know what the
markets gonna do you can't be certain
about the next trend or the next
downturn or the next bubble that's gonna
burst you can't know those things so you
have to do the same thing after control
what you can control which is you gotta
gather intelligence you got to analyze
the metrics that you can track you got
to train yourself and your team to be
prepared for both the known and also be
prepared for the unknown figure out what
the likely contingencies are then have
some plans to execute if those
contingencies occur maintain discipline
as an organization so that you have the
flexibility and the responsiveness to
maneuver effectively and efficiently
when the unburden
what actually happens so instead of
suffering and falling apart in the chaos
you can take advantage of it and win and
that's business and life is the same the
enemy is not always clear in life it can
be hard to tell who's gonna try and
bring you now or what is going to bring
you down there's distractions there are
things out there that will do you harm
that are so camouflaged you can't see
them at all
there are deceitful people there are
accidents that can occur and diseases
that take root and there's bad luck and
there's Murphy's lawn there's times when
it seems that the whole world is against
you the whole world is the enemy and the
same rules apply
control what you can't control you train
hard learn maintain the unmitigated
daily discipline in all things rule
number three don't go against your
values is it ever okay to violate core
values to achieve a goal okay so first
of all really obvious your values and
your goals should be aligned they should
not be adversarial they shouldn't be
counter to each other and if you think
about what your goals are your goals
should be set up in a way that they
support your values and vice versa
that's just the way it is so I'm not
sure where this is gonna be an issue if
you're setting up goals that are
contrary to your values you've got some
issues now I guess if you had the goal
of winning the blue belt jiu-jitsu
championships and in order to win you
you cheated like you claimed someone was
reaping your leg and you said are you
tap and you get the guy to qualified and
you win that's could be an example right
yeah now do I support that no you know
that's wrong you you go in against the
values of actually the values of martial
arts to do that so you didn't win
anything and you didn't achieve your
goal because you weren't actually the
best so I say no on that one uh another
one let's say you wanted to make a
certain level of profit at your company
so you cheated a little bit on the
quality of the manufacturing and you
sold items that weren't quite reliable
do I support that no right for animal
and why let me tell you why because your
goal your goal is not even aligned with
your goal itself because when you start
making substandard manufactured items
what's gonna happen in the long run
people gonna say we don't like these
yeah we're not gonna buy them anymore so
you didn't win you might have wanted the
short term but you didn't win and and
again you're going against your value
you should have values that you don't
want to you know take profit over making
good product and again in the long run
that value is gonna cost you right
people aren't going to
to buy your product anymore rule number
four have a mission I need a mission we
all need a mission that's what life
should be is a mission that's what gives
your life purpose and focus and drive
and ultimately satisfaction now that
mission can be the job you work at it
can be providing for your family or it
can be getting better at jiu-jitsu or
stronger at Olympic lifting or starting
a business that you want to grow and
build and take over the world and
sometimes people ask me what to do if
they don't know what their mission is or
what their mission should be and I tell
them if they're in that situation to go
help someone gonna help someone else
make that your mission because that will
make you better and it'll make the world
better and eventually from that you'll
see what your mission is rule number
five detach and refine how do self
awareness self assessment and self
improvement begin and how do they
continue over time try to imagine the
way other people see you and what other
people are thinking of you and one place
where this happens and it definitely
happened to me is when I started getting
put in charge of things I started
thinking about other people's
perspectives what what are they seeing
if you're in charge then what are your
subordinates see you do what are your
subordinates here you say what kind of
representation are they receiving
in if you work for someone else it's the
same questions what does the boss see me
do what does the boss hear me say what
kind of representation am i making of
myself to my boss and then you start
thinking about what are your friends and
family think what do they see what do
they hear and so the question becomes
how well do you represent yourself what
shortfalls do you have now when you
first start looking it's like you're
looking at an overgrown lawn there are
some big obvious problems so you do a
broad just kind of general cut of the
grass you fix some of the big easy
problems that are obvious but once
you've done that you've gotten rid of
some of those big obvious problems you
notice some more detailed problems so
then you handle them and once you've got
those handled you see even smaller and
more detail the issues so you start
trying to fix them and that's what you
do with yourself you continually detach
and then you look and then you refine
and then you detach and then you look
and then you refine and then you detach
and you look and then you refine that's
what you do that's how you get better
and that process doesn't stop it can't
stop because if you stop refining then
and then the weeds grow back and the
next thing you know you can't see
yourself anymore and when you can't see
yourself anymore when you stop looking
at you yourself then you accept you
accept anything
then that's wrong don't accept the
faults don't give yourself the benefit
of the doubt you've got to be your own
harshest critic and hold the line rule
number six start small
I say this to people all the time most
important here is it isn't me it's you
and sure you may have grabbed some
little foothold from the podcast or from
one of the books but it isn't me that
changes you it's you you set the small
goals you achieve those goals then set
some more and achieve those and set some
more goals maybe a little bit bigger but
not that much bigger just start to start
small start with changing tomorrow
morning just tomorrow morning get that
squared away and then move on to the
next day and the next and move your life
to a better place one little step one
little victory at a time rule number
seven be a good leader I'm a veteran of
the infantry and when I took over a fire
team for the first time I made the
mistake of drawing hard lines in the
sand this immediately alienated members
of that team if you draw a lot hard
lines in the sand and eventually you
realize that they're either unrealistic
or people can't maintain them you've set
yourself up for failure what is that
exactly like so it's like no matter what
we will not that bla bla bla
yeah there's the leg no matter that what
we will we will win every single road
march that we do as a fire team in this
while while we're here on this training
thing hmm okay well guess what that's a
that's hard to do there's other there's
some other fire team
that her also want to win and and so
you've drawn a hard line of sand that's
not really a good example of a good
example to take no matter what we're
gonna muster every morning at 4:30 in
the morning mm no matter what and you
know then the guys are out on patrol
until 2:38 in the morning and now the
next morning a good no matter what well
it's it's not good for them it's
unrealistic so you drew a hard line in
the sand and now you got to back it down
so and all you have to do is soften the
statement a little bit
hey guys to the best of our ability if
we can we're gonna get here every
morning at 4:30 for muster there's a
little there's a little room to play
there right and that's that's fine so
again I I there's there's not a lot of
there's not a question here but one of
the reasons I think that that I wanted
to talk about it was cuz I think people
look at me and even hear me on a
peripheral level and they think all I
bet Chuck will just lay down the hard
night it's my way or the highway right
yeah and and the the opposite is
actually true and the reason that I came
to that conclusion was because I worked
for leaders like that and I hated
working for leaders like that so I tried
to never be a leader like that rule
number eight find your purpose I can't
this is an expression that is vilified
in our minds beginning at a young age
every time a young child announces this
decision they are corrected the first
adult that hears it asked them whether
or not they have even tried generally
this confrontation will result in the
child giving their task
another attempt until their attention
span moves on to something else the
adult will see this and chuckle to
themselves with knowledge that this is
just a child who is yet to learn the art
of art and virtue of perseverance by the
time this child comes of age however
they will have been told by adults more
times than they could count that there
is no such thing as
can't it is interesting then to think
about how many adults seem to proclaim
this expression in their lives it is
because is it because like many things
that adults tell children they are
simply telling the child a general rule
that the child must follow but can be
broken once one has grown or is it
because these adults are simply
repeating what they were told as
children without thoroughly examining
what the phrase I can't truly suggests
if you confronted an adult that claims
they can't do something with the same
question about whether or not they have
tried the answer will almost always be
yes
adults have learned enough to know that
it is unreasonable to say they can't
until they have at least tried once
therefore the real question that we
should be asking in responses have you
tried everything have you exhausted
every possible option scenario
combination tool and approach I do not
simply refer to the ones that you knew
of at the time he decided to undertake
your task I mean have you re also
researched possibilities that you had
known about have you determined whether
or not there is another person out there
that has performed the exact same task
you are attempting or at least something
similar have you exhausted this research
have you read every book blog journal
magazine bathroom stall and website if
the answer to any of these questions is
no then go back and try again
because if you don't because you don't
truly know if you can do something until
you've tried absolutely everything the
fact of the matter is that rarely if
ever is the answer to all these
questions yes therefore what is it that
people actually mean when they say I
can't a more accurate but more verbose
way of saying it would be I don't care
about or want enough this task or the
resultant benefits of it in order to do
all that is necessary to achieve it I
was told
numbers of times by people during my
month of marathons that they couldn't
run one marathon let alone 31 straight
every now and then when I had time I
would discuss what they'd said we would
jointly conclude that if something they
cared about and depended on them doing
so it would be possible the most common
example I used was if someone had a gun
to your child's head do you think you
could do it then
therefore the phrase I can't denotes a
lack of investment as opposed to a lack
of potential or ability I do not mean to
say that every person I had this
conversation with should have had the
motivation to run marathons it was
something that I decided to do not them
I merely wanted to express to them what
I am expressing here given the right
purpose and enough time you can rule
number nine don't fight alone everyone
that's out there grinding working
driving trucks pouring concrete
hammering on a project building bridges
or building software sewing some
garments or sewing of field farmers
factory workers engineers electricians
plumbers and pilots and ground crew and
cooks and waitresses to everyone out
there working hard and listening to this
and just trying to get yourself a little
bit better today than you were yesterday
thanks for listening and as you meet
struggles and as you struggle to stay on
the path first of all remember you don't
have to fight alone reach out to your
comrades in arms call for fire support
when you need it we win wars because we
stick together and when we stick
together we can overcome any enemy
and the struggles that you face when
they when they do try to flank you do a
Jody did do what a soldier does turn
into the ambush turn toward the enemy
fire and attack and rule number 10 the
last one before a very special bonus
clip pick up the brass I think if you
took out the trash sometime you're the
boss but you can see that the trash is
getting overfilled and you just grab it
and take it out maybe in your mind you
think you'd be losing respect but you
actually didn't be a Dalek the fact that
we want to see those he's a good guy and
you want to and you still come a day to
discipline the more that you treat them
with respect and respect you they're
gonna know that you're not too happy
then I know that you're down to earth
when I do come advertise be ready I
picked up brass I clean the ranges with
the boys I would recommend that panel
Judy didn't make people think on job
news even better to do that actually do
I had stuff to do but what I'm gonna do
they kept brass with the boys baby
relationships set the example
they respect you for it
I've got a really special bonus clip
from Jocko and how to be organized that
I think you're really gonna enjoy before
that I want to know what did you learn
from Jocko today he dropped a lot of
knowledge bombs what are you gonna apply
to your life or your business leave it
down the comments below when you write
it down you're much more likely to
actually take action so put it in the
comments thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip I'd appreciate any input
or advice you have on how to record and
track objectives in a functional in a
reliable manner as I'm subjected to a
lot of information each day week month
I'm definitely overloaded to remember it
my self discipline equals freedom so
yeah a few things first first of all
definitely write the things down in one
place and it sounds like since you're
moving all the time or you're going to
meetings carry out just a nice little
notebook with you and write the things
down as you get tasked with them then on
top of that you have to have a master
list of some kind either paper or
digital I'm gonna probably recommend
digital to tracked things
overall in a prioritized method so if
you could task something in a meeting in
your little notebook you come back you
put it in the right place in the master
task list and then like twice a day to
consolidate the information that's in
the little notebook you have into the
big master list and then before you go
to bed at night you organize those
things by priority on the master list
you put the most important thing at the
top and that's what you're going to
attack the next day that's part one on
how you get these things organized now
the part two is you've got to schedule
this stuff and actually I always say
this when people have trouble with tasks
put them on the calendar to you know
actually Jamie does that for me when
Jamie's got something for me to do she
just doesn't email me and say hey you
need to do this she puts it on the
calendar so I look at my calendar boom
there it is I gotta go do this whatever
this task is done
so put these things on your calendar and
that includes scheduling time on your
calendar so that you can have time to
consolidate your list and do a review of
your lists you know whether that takes
that probably take 15 minutes to do and
I guess there's a bunch of apps you can
use and I'm sure people will make
recommendations but there's a ton of
to-do list apps including there's one
there's native ones on all the different
phones so you could look at that as a
possible a voice recorder mmm you can
either use the voice recorder app you
have or you can carry around a little
mini voice recorder then you can just
take notes with that and then you
consolidate those notes from your from
your voice recorder into your master
task list every day and then you just
kind of prioritize and execute if you
tell yourself a story long enough you
start to believe it don't you believe
you act like I have Tulsa what a whale
out of handcuffed lightning though
Thunder in jail now you know I'm bad
over the last week I've murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success is it can
take between 18 and 254 days of taking
action for a new habit to stick I've
created a new course called 2:54
confidence or every single day for 254
days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access